demi lovato is embracing who she really
is
the 28 year old covers the march issue
of glamour magazine
inside she revealed that her recent
split with ex-fiance
actor max eric helped her embrace her
sexuality and allowed her to become
more herself stating quote when i
started getting older i started
realizing how queer
i really am this past year i was engaged
to a man
and when it didn't work i was like this
is a huge sign
i thought i was going to spend my life
with someone now that i wasn't going to
i felt this sense of relief that i could
live my truth
you have to prioritize what's important
to you she goes on to say when it came
to hooking up with women
it felt better some of the guys i was
hanging out with
when it would come time to be sexual or
intimate i would have this kind of
visceral reaction
i'm just gonna say it all the singer
also clarifies that those feelings had
nothing to do with the person she was
with
she just found herself appreciating the
friendship of the opposite sex
rather than romance any time that you
suppress
a part of yourself it's gonna overflow
and while demi says she knows quote
what i am and who i am she's not rushing
to publicly share her sexuality and is
using this time to really study and
educate myself on my journey which is
something demi is giving us a glimpse of
in her new youtube documentary demi
lovato
dancing with the devil i'm re-birthing i
am starting over
i'm engaged i've really struggled with
this
are you entirely sober now i've had a
lot of lives
like my cat you know i'm on my ninth leg
i'm ready to get back to
doing what i love which is making music
i'm not living my life for other people
or their headlines or their twitter
comments
[Music]
demi also goes on to share that although
she's had her fair share of struggles
she continues to rise above telling
glamour quote
i think that when the universe shuts one
door it opens another
or there's a window to open it just
depends on your perspective
and how you choose to look at it i focus
on
just what i see in the mirror and that's
um
a beautiful person i know that nobody
can take
who i am away from me